[Music]
joining us now is Brett Bear anchor and
executive editor of Special Report and
author of the new book to the rescue the
Constitution Brett um what do you make
of the last 72 hours from this
Administration the back and forth the
retracting tweets the now we have no
idea apparently these major attacks 22
years after 911 we still don't have the
Intel yeah lur good evening thanks for
having me on I think um the
Administration has had a tough time
communicating how to react to all of
this the president obviously gives his
uh 3 minute actually 2 minute 55 second
speech on Saturday we don't see him uh
for a couple of days and then the
Administration has been trying to figure
out how to talk about this especially
when it comes to Iran um that word was
not in President Biden's speech today
Iran uh they've spent the past couple of
days talking about the $6 billion dollar
and how not a a dinar of that money has
gone out uh and talking about all of
that but not talking about uh enforcing
sanctions and um the fact that Iran has
been flush with money Iranian oil money
selling exports to China in the tune of
$30 billion dollar just this past year
so talking about this has been tough and
one of the toughest things is the
intelligence surrounding it uh as you
saw with Jake suvin today now um Kent
jampier was asked about Biden's absence
Brett after Saturday uh and what might
have contributed to it watch
did the president's need to be
interviewed by the special counsel
yesterday impede or keep him from giving
the remarks he gave today yesterday was
a federal holiday presidents have to do
multiple things at once and again the
president has to handle many things at
once Brett all of us came to work on a
Federal holiday yesterday but I guess um
couldn't couldn't do it but he multitask
well yeah you know they put out this
picture of him meeting with officials
and he says he's talked to a number of
world leaders and they they listed all
the calls he's made uh but obviously in
a situation like this there's a call for
a president to get in front of a camera
uh multiple times uh to calm the
situation to support an ally uh to make
sure that the enemies of our country and
of Israel uh don't act he got to those
points today and he hit the marks um but
there was a lot of wanting from his
critics about where he's been Brett
really quickly what can we learn from
your new book which is obviously going
to be a huge bestseller to the rescue of
the Constitution how does this apply to
what's happening today well listen
George Washington without him we
wouldn't have had a country a lot of
people forget how from the end of the
Revolutionary War to the formation of
our country the country was falling
apart the colonies were were just not
getting along at all and it was George
Washington that held it all together he
has a lot to to that could factor into
to how we look at today we're in a
partisan time uh but he was a united
figure that we could all learn from it
was about America all about America
Brett thank you so much congratulations
on another destined to be huge
bestseller thanks so much thanks Lord
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else